today I'm here at you to you post you a
question what is life it has been really
puzzled me for more than 25 years and
probably will continuing so for the next
25 years this is the ceases I did when
I'm still in undergraduate school when
people while my colleagues my classmates
still treat computer as be calculator I
start to teach computer tuner I built a
digital native videos and try to learn
from a real native videos just to do one
thing search for and after a very simple
your network genetic algorithms and so
look at the pattern he almost identical
as the real life a very striking
learning experience for 20 years boy
life is a learning program we look at
all those wonderful world every species
has his own learning program the
learning program is genome and the code
of that program is DNA the different
genome of each species represent
different survival strategy
it represents hundreds of millings years
of evolution to interaction between
every species ancestor and the
environment I was really fascinated
about the world about the DNA about you
know language of the life the program of
learning so I decided to co-founded the
Institute to read them IRA many of them
probably we read more than half of the
prior animal genomes in the world I mean
up to date we did learn a lot with this
sequence also one species
many many times human genome we sequence
the first Asian I sequencer myself many
many times just to take advantage of
that platform look at all those
rebidding
base pairs atcg you don't understand
anything there but look at that one base
pair those five letters there AG GAA
these five slips represent a very
specific laboratory in Tibetan
population around the gene code I pass
one that gene has been proved it's
highly selected is the most significant
signature of positive selection to
parents for the higher editor adaptation
you know what these five snips was from
a result of integration of tennis over
or tennis over like individuals into
humans this is the reason why we need to
read those genomes to understand the
history to understand what kind of
process learning process the genome has
been through for the meanings of years
by reading a genome can give you a lot
of information tells you the bugs in the
genome
I mean birth defects you know monetary
disorders there by reading a drop of
blood could tell you why you got a fever
all tells you which medicine a dosage
needs to be used when you are sick
especially on cancer a lot of things
could be studied but look at that thirty
years ago where was your PO in China
only 0.67 percent of Chinese at our
population have diabetic look and now
eleven percent genetics cannot change
over thirty years a one in one
generation it must be something
different right environment
lifestyle even an identical twins could
develop totally differently it could be
one become very obvious another smart
one developer cancer not is not not
mentioning living in a very stressed
environment I moved to engine 10 years
ago for some reason people may know
if the jeans under stress you behave
totally differently life is a journey
and G is just a starting point not the
end you have this static risk of certain
disease when you were born but every day
you made different choices and those
choices will increase or decrease the
risk of certain disease but do you know
where are you on the curve once the past
curve looked like what kind of decision
you're facing every day and what kind of
decision is the right one to make your
own right curve over your life journey
what's that the only thing you cannot
change you cannot reverse reverse back
it's time probably not yet maybe in the
future Wow you cannot change your
decision you've made but can we do
something there
can we actually try to run a multiple
options on me and try to predict right
on the consequence and be able to make
the right choice after all we are our
choices this lady beetles came to me
afterwards twenty-five years ago I made
a lady beetles the digital native
beetles try to simulate that real lady
beetles can I make a digital me to
stimulate me I understand that you're
now who could become you know much more
sophisticated and complicated there can
I make that one and try to wrong
multiple options on that digital me to
compute that they I could live in
different universe in parallel at the
same time now we choose whatever is good
for me I probably have the most
comprehensive digital me in the planet
and spend a lot of dollars on me on
myself and the digital me Tommy
I have generic risk of God by all those
things there you need different
technology to do that in the proteins
genes you need you know metabolize
antibodies you need to screen all your
body about but here
enviros covered on you or in you you
need to you know have all this smart
device there you know smart cars my
house smart
you know tables my watch smartphone to
travel activities their environment is
important everything is important and
don't forget the smart toilet it's such
a waste right every day so much
invaluable information just has been
flashed into the water and you need them
you need to master all of them you need
to be able to match your everything
around you and compute them and the
digital me told me i'm genetic defect i
have a very high risk of god which I
don't feel anything now I'm still
healthy but look at my uric acid levels
double than the normal range and the
digital means search against all the
medicine block and tell me okay
you could drink a bull perturb tea I
cannot even pronounce it right that is
from the Chinese or wisdom and I drink
that tea for three months my rib your
castle out of back to normal
I mean worked for me all those thousands
of years wisdoms worked for me I was not
ki but I probably not lucky for you all
this existing knowledge in the world
cannot be possibly efficient enough
personalized enough for yourself the
only way to make that digital me work is
to nerve from yourself you have to ask a
lot of questions about yourself what if
I'm being gellick now here you don't
probably see it but I do I'm you know
what if I alas what I've taken meta for
me was supposedly to be live longer what
if I climb Mount Everest and all that
easy or wrong marathon
what if I drink a bottle of multi which
is a Chinese sneaker and I get ready
drunk I I was doing a video rehearsal
last time where with the frogs here when
I was drunk and I totally delivered a
different speech
what if I walk less right it has been a
less stress right so it probably never
happened to me I was really stressed
every day but but I hope I could be nest
rest her either a study told us even
with the same planner have totally
different glucose level reaction over
different individuals for me what is the
right breakfast for me I need to do two
weeks expect control experiments of
testing all kinds of different food
ingredients on me and check my body
reaction and I don't know the precision
nutrition for me for myself there I want
to search all the Chinese of wisdoms
about how can I live longer a health I
did it
some of them are really unseeable I did
is once loss of Tobruk by not eating for
seven days I did a fasting for seven
days with six partners of mine look at
those people
one smile you know why he smile he
cheated he drank one cup of coffee and
night we caught it from the data we
measured everything from the data we'll
be able to check them and we can really
see for example my immune system it just
to give you a little hint there my
immune system changed dramatically over
24 hours there and my anybody regulates
my proteins for that dramatic change
everybody doing that even we essentially
totally different at the very beginning
and that probably will be an interesting
treatment in the future for the cancer
and things like that it become very very
interesting but something you probably
don't want to try like drinking fecal
water from a healthy individual which
will make you feel healthy this is from
the Oh Chinese wisdom is look at that
right like this 1700 years ago it's
already there on the book but I still
hate the smell I want you to find out
the two way to do it and maybe find a
combination of cocktails or bacterias
and drink it probably make me better so
I'm trying to do that
even I'm trying this heart is so
difficult to test out all possible
conditions it's not possible to do all
kinds of environment experiment at all
but we do have seven dealing learning
program in this planet seven billion and
every program is running at different
conditions in doing different experiment
can we all measure them seven years ago
I wrote an editorial s/a in science to
celebrate chat the human genome you know
10 years adversary' I said sequence
yourself for one and for all but now I'm
going to say digitalize yourself for one
and for all when we make this digital me
to digital we when we try to you from
the Internet of life when people can
learn from each other when people can
learn from the experience their data
when people could really form a teach to
me by themselves they we learn from it
the digital we will be totally different
with a digital me but it could only come
from the digital me and this is what I
try to propose here join me become we
and everybody should build up their own
digital me because only by that you are
no more about you about me about us
about the question I just posed at the
very beginning what is life thank you
[Applause]
once like quick passive view I mean the
work is amazing I suspect one question
people have is as soon as we look
forward to these amazing technical
possibilities of personalized medicine
in the near term it feels like they're
only going to be affordable for a few
people right it costs many dollars to do
all the sequencing and so forth but is
this gonna lead to a kind of you know
increasing inequality or is is that is
do you have this vision that the
knowledge that you get from the pioneers
can actually be pretty quickly
disseminated to help a broader or a
broader set of recipients well good
question well tell you that 70 years ago
vonda BGI and a served as CEO position
at the company there are the only go
there for me to do is to drive the
sequencing Kosta I started from 100
million dollar per human genome now is a
couple hundred dollars per humans you
know the only reason to do it is to get
more people benefit from it so for the
digital me the same thing now you
probably need you know whatever million
dollars to digital person I think has to
be hundred-dollar it has to be free for
many of those people that you know
urgently need that so this is our goal
and this is and this since there with
all these merging the technology I think
in the very near future let's say three
to five years you will come to reality
and this is the whole idea why I founded
my you know the I Kappa X my second
company's really trying to sort of get
the cost down to a level every
individual could have the benefit all
right so the dream is not elite health
services for a few its is to really try
and actually make overall health care
much much more cost-effective because of
what was started from some early
adaptors for joy people believing ideas
and so on but eventually would become
everybody's benefit what gene I think
it's it's got to be true to say you're
one of the most amazing scientific minds
in the planet is the honor to have you
been here with us thank you so much
thank you